season two of the bear features a
carefully considered progression of
flavors that will leave viewers hungry
for more but if you're looking to
deconstruct the dramedy well right this
way your table awaits
season one of the bear concluded with a
deus ex machina in the form of canned
tomatoes Richie finally gives Carmi the
letter that Mikey Left Behind which
leads to the discovery of the roughly
three hundred thousand dollars in cash
the Jimmy lent the previous and late
executive chef Carmi decides to use the
money to reopen the beef as the bear the
family-style fine dining establishment
that's been his dream since at least
High School
season two quickly comes to a boil when
Carmi Sydney and new project manager
sugar realize they've underestimated how
expensive and involved that process will
be they decide to come clean to Jimmy
about the money and hopes he'll be
willing to invest even more Carmi boldly
bets that if the restaurant isn't
turning a profit in 18 months he'll sign
over the deed sugar in Sydney are
stunned because it should take at least
six months to get a new restaurant off
the ground to get in the black the gang
will have to do it in three that's a CP
what's a CP the karmi problem throughout
season 2 Carmi and his staff struggled
to schedule and pass inspections as
nearly every step forward results in two
steps back sugar who reluctantly reveals
that she's pregnant plays the Damsel in
Distress to manipulate Jimmy into
twisting some arms so that they can make
their launch date season two of The Bear
is an illustration of the adage that
things often look worse before they look
better that applies to construction
projects many Development Career
prospects finances recovery love and
life
through a combination of flashbacks and
present-day conversations about the past
we learned that Carmi was considerably
less cool in high school than we might
have imagined not only did he speak with
a stutter it seems he never had a
girlfriend or went to a party spending
most of his free time doodling in
notebooks the sketches that weren't of
pants or food were of a girl who carmy
had a crush on a spectacled cutie
affectionately referred to as Claire
Bearer in the show's main timeline Carmi
and Claire have a meat cute at a
convenience store refrigerator in which
he pretends not to remember her name and
gives her a fake number confident Claire
gets his real digits off of fact and the
two begin to hang out on a regular basis
it becomes clear that Carmi really likes
Claire bear and has since childhood and
she'll eventually confess that she's had
a major crush on him this whole time too
nevertheless the prospect of having a
girlfriend stresses him out in the
Christmas episode fishes Carmi gets
upset almost to the point of having a
panic attack when Mikey and Richie try
to set him up with Claire bear later
Richie suggests he won't let good things
happen to him but what's probably going
on is that in the same way sugar is
worried about becoming a mother he's
worried about getting into a
relationship because of his family's
mental health history and dysfunction he
also realizes that a serious girlfriend
could represent an obstacle to his
Ambitions as a chef when karmi offended
both Sidney and Marcus near the end of
season one The sous chef and the pastry
chef bonded in a way that hinted at a
future romance but when season 2 begins
Sydney is noticeably awkward around
Marcus and in an entirely different way
around her business partner Carmi the
implication is that Sydney is not
interested in Marcus but might be
interested in her culinary Idol there's
still conflict between them she wants a
Michelin star he doesn't care but also
palpable chemistry then karmy bumps into
Claire just when he and Sid were about
to embark on a restaurateur to reset
their pallets instead Sydney has to go
It Alone setting up a subtle and
well-balanced love triangle let's just
hang out with Claire I mean that seems
moderately healthy right
who's Claire Sydney's able to table her
complicated feelings for Carmi but she
can't ignore the fact that his budding
relationship with Claire is getting in
the way of their working relationship
her father entered contacts within the
industry warned her that she shouldn't
make the sleep with someone she doesn't
trust carmi's divided attention puts
more weight on her shoulders which makes
her question whether she's doing the
right thing getting in the way of
practical matters like finalizing the
menu and fixing broken refrigerator
handles is the uncomfortable idea that
maybe she's jealous of Claire even so
it's Sid who encourages Carmi to admit
she's his girlfriend with only days left
to open Sid wonders where she stands
with Carmi personally and professionally
two opens with Marcus sitting next to
someone in a hospital bed lovingly
rubbing their hands we learn his mother
is terminally ill and caring for her has
taken a toll on him a once promising
football Prospect Marcus worked his way
up from fast food to carmi's Kitchen to
support her and remain close by while
the restaurant is being deep cleaned
he's given the opportunity to Stage for
a chef in Copenhagen as once in a
lifetime as the trip is he Frets about
leaving his mother behind Marcus Comes
Alive once abroad studying under Chef
Luca at first he's so intimidated he
can't operate a pair of tweezers without
mentioning karmy by name Luca tells
Marcus that one Chef made him realize he
wasn't the best in the world and he
didn't have to be which took off some
pressure Luca used the kitchen to better
himself and make the most of his life He
suggests that Marcus do the same and
teaches him to be confident open and
inspired while walking home one night
Marcus happens upon a local who's been
in a terrible bicycle accident he
rescues the man who thanks him and rides
away the incident is a symbolic lesson
in the selflessness of service that
parallels his experience with his mother
and as a chef when Marcus returns to
Chicago he's not only written recipes
for three new desserts he has a new
outlook on life and an improved
perspective of his own self-worth line
cook Tina wasn't a particularly likable
character in season 1 but started to
come around by the final episode and at
the very start of season 2 it's clear
that she's all in on the bear while
Carmen Sydney and sugar try to put out
little fires everywhere Tina sucks up to
the chef she once resented clearly
angling for a promotion it isn't long at
all before she gets her wish the new
Chef De Cuisine offers her the job
almost apologetically she assumes the
longtime employee who was so set in her
ways won't want to put in the time to do
what it'll take but Tina
enthusiastically accepts her invitation
to attend culinary school while the
restaurant is being renovated Carmi
lends and ultimately gifts her his
chef's knife and Tina learns to see
herself in a new light when she excels
in the program we can deduce the Tina's
thorny personality was a result of her
insecurities
deep down her lack of a formal education
made her feel defensive in the way she
perks up when asked to join other
students at a bar indicates that she may
not have had many friends though she
dreaded it all the change that's
happening at the sandwich shop has
worked out in Tina's favor
let's be honest this is Richie season
the once problem-causing cousin of the
verzottos is a changed man and it's all
thanks to some streaky Forks but before
karmi sends Richie to work at his old
world-renowned restaurant we learn a
little about the Brash sandwich rapper's
backstory during episode six Natalie I'm
not like this because I'm in Van Halen I
am in Van Halen because I'm like this
not so long ago Richie was a doting
husband with a kid on the way his wife
Tiffany wanted more out of life
including a nice house and a good school
district so he lied to her about already
having secured a job with Jimmy the
years between this uncomfortable moment
at Christmas dinner and the present are
still a mystery so we don't know exactly
what went down with the job or their
marriage back to those Forks his bad
attitude results in a Stern talking to
by Garrett who orders him to respect
himself and the restaurant a switch
flips in Richie's brain he begins to
embrace the commitment that's required
to execute high-end service and by the
time he hand delivers a deep dish pizza
he's completely intoxicated with the
idea after a full-throated Taylor Swift
jam session in his car Richie returns to
the bear ready to run front of house
like a rock star but first he apologizes
to sugar and comes to terms with the
fact that Tiffany is getting remarried
Richie's new threads are a metaphor he
realizes Carmi didn't send him a way to
get him out of his hair he gave him the
chance to become who he's always wanted
to be
with a sure to be legendary episode 6
the Bear shows us what life was like for
karmi sugar and the other characters in
the berzado family's orbit it it's
Christmas Eve and Carmi is home to
celebrate with his mother's traditional
Italian Seven Fishes I make things
beautiful for them
no one makes things beautiful for me
customary seafood dishes and bears
become loaded metaphors
B gives a blessing about love
demonstrated through service and
sacrifice and the guests debate whether
bears are empathetic aggressive or both
for the verzados it's both an unstable
Donna loses her cool more than once she
melts down as she violently grabs Sugar
by the chin then again at dinner when
she doesn't feel properly appreciated
and her daughter dares to ask if she's
okay finally Donna drives her car into
the house as sugar watches in horrified
disbelief it's clear that she and sugar
have a toxic relationship in which the
child feels more responsibility for the
well-being of the parent rather than the
other way around Carmi meanwhile is more
focused on Mikey though he won't fully
realize the seriousness of his brother's
illness until after his death it's
becoming apparent to Carmi that Mikey
and his family are plagued by
generational trauma his cousin Michelle
sees it too and offers him Refuge he's
left to decide whether he should stay
and try to fix his family or whether
he's better off alone and away it's a
question he's still wrestling with
leading into the finale
in episode 10 titled the bear the new
restaurant soft opens for friends and
family Marcus has perfected four new
desserts including a Savory take on
cannoli that he's dubbed the Michael in
honor of the madness and genius that was
their former boss Tina is seamlessly
executing more refined dishes Richie is
thriving as the maitre d Sydney proudly
dons the monogrammed Chef's coat that
her Partners gifted her but karmi's
feeling the Heat and can't be bothered
to visit Claire in the dining room the
walk-in door handle which has been loose
all season breaks off trapping the
executive chef inside just his orders
begin to come in Rapid Fire and one of
the new hires goes missing that's okay
is he's stuck in the walk-in yeah yeah
with karmi literally on ice the staff
Rises to the challenge we can see that
karmi has helped to improve everyone
else's station but his own the crew are
all more functional than they were when
the series started but carmi's having an
existential crisis in a refrigerator
besides carmi's predicament Pete spots a
still unwell Donna outside she can't
bring herself to come in and Sugar's
left assuming her mom wasn't proud
enough to show though the night is a
success from the patrons perspective
it's still full of stress behind the
scenes most of which is brought on by
carmi's unresolved issues
season 2 of the bear is mainly about
whether the new restaurant will open on
schedule and that question is more or
less answered by the finale but on a
character level there's still plenty of
Unfinished Business to be addressed in
season three it's possible that a
reformed Richie could try to reconcile
with Tiffany before the wedding sugar is
still pregnant which means next season
will almost certainly see the birth of
her child but the bigger looming
questions have to do with karmi Sydney
and Marcus while carmi's fridged he has
a panic attack during which his memories
of Claire are intercut with his memories
of Sydney he's been in love with Claire
all his life but the thought of Sydney
is what pulls him out of his spiral in
the previous episode the two supported
each other as they repaired a table and
with Claire standing just outside the
walk-in Carmi delivers a monologue she
definitely wasn't supposed to hear we'll
find out whether he can juggle his love
life and his work life in part three
similarly Sydney flubs acting normally
around Marcus who asks her out just
before the dinner Rush begins when she
rebuffs him he's hurt and takes it out
on her for most of the night regardless
of whether player Returns the next love
triangle looks to be between Carmi
Sydney and Marcus finally season 2 ends
how it began with Marcus's mom in the
pandemonium of opening his worst fear
comes true as he misses multiple calls
from her nurse signaling tragic news as
of the making of this video the bear has
neither been renewed or canceled but all
signs point to an eventual renewal
announcement if the show does get
another green light expect the series to
return no earlier than June 2024 as
seasons 1 and 2 dropped in June 2022 and
2023 respectively
foreign